so what is the simplest and most
beautiful triangle in the world Brady oh
the Bermuda Triangle
well is it the type of triangles I'm
thinking I couldn't think of another
famous triangle you mean an equilateral
time we're lateral triangle that's what
I'm thinking of well there we go an
equilateral triangle which inscribed in
a circle let us take any other point on
this circle for example we take a point
right here and we connect it with the
vertices of this circle all right so
we're going to label these things B C
and D Brady what do you think could
possibly be true about these red
segments it could be true that B and C
are the same as D added together or yes
amazingly it is actually true that's
true
yes B plus C is indeed equal to D not D
factorial not G factorial definitely
just an exclamation point okay now there
are ways to prove this without Ptolemy
but since we have worked so hard to
prove Ptolemy why not use it
do we see a quadrilateral yeah
absolutely
I need those green sides I don't know
what they are but looks like calling
them all is is good because this is an
equilateral triangle so by Potamus
theorem what do we have the product of
the opposite sides a B and a C if I add
those products I must get the product of
the diagonals the green diagonal is a
there are diagonal is d so we're going
to get a G hmm again we see repetition
let's kill it we divide by a and we get
exactly what we wanted
the two shorter segments add up to the
lung I remember spending a lot of time
on this problem in middle school
I did not know about ptolemies theorem
and I did not know about inversion it is
possible to do this problem with similar
triangles but they are not all drawn you
have to come up in a very imaginative
way with those similar triangles so
Ptolemy theorem really wins in terms of
elegance and simplicity okay we have now
a regular pentagon or at least my
version the closest I could draw by hand
here also it is inscribed in a circle so
what can Ptolemy tell us about this
situation first of all we want a
quadrilateral not a pentagon so we are
going to select randomly four of the
vertices let's say the bottom four we
now need to draw the remaining segments
between them those segments happen to be
diagonals of the pentagon they are all
of equal length because they all
participate in these triangles two of
whose sides are green these are from the
Pentagon it's any rate we need to label
things let's say a for the sides of the
pentagon and we have two more but we
don't care about them we label B all of
those diagonals there is really nothing
else in the Pentagon they're only the
sides under-diagnosed
what is their ratio if I take the
diagonal which looks is the larger of
the two and divided by the side which
number do you think Brady are we going
to get it's a ratio could be the most
famous ratio okay let's not get ahead of
the game let's see what happens so Tommy
tells us about this bottom quadrilateral
that if I multiply the opposite sides so
a times B and the other opposite sides a
times a I'm going to get
the product of the two diagonals which
is B times B excellent let's put
everything on one side B squared minus a
B minus a squared is equal to zero all
right any mathematician looking at this
says mmm
this is a homogeneous equation I can do
miracles with it in other words let's
just divide by a squared and see what
that would give us so B squared over a
squared minus now one of those days will
cancel B over a minus one cause a
squared divided by a squared just 1 and
that's 0 hmm well here is the ratio that
we were interested in B over a if I
write this ratio as X we end up with a
quadratic equation and when we solve it
using the quadratic formula we get 1
plus or minus 1 squared plus 4 times 1
divided by 2 or 1 plus or minus square
root of 5/2
wait hold on we still have two choices
is it possible that for some pentagons
you get one of those roots and for other
pentagons the other word I don't think
so one of those roots is utterly
impossible
the smaller root which is 1 minus square
root of 5 over 2 is negative but the
larger root is positive and it is the
famous golden ratio so what we have
shown using thalamus is that if you take
any diagonal of a regular pentagon and
you divide it by any one of its sides
you're going to get the golden ratio
I think our journey was worth this video
was a continuation of their epic video
about the proof of Ptolemies theorem
there are links on the screen and down
in the description
to that video and other stuff you might
find interesting no matter where you are
on this railroad you build your station
as people from both villages will walk
exactly the same distance